[Music]
we're finishing Today's Show in Idaho
where two new attorneys have been added
to the prosecution team in the case
against accused quadruple killer Brian
coburger later County Magistrate Judge
Megan Marshall granted a motion from the
state requesting additional help for the
County prosecutor Deputy attorney
generals Jeff Nye and Ingrid Beatty will
now work alongside prosecutor Bill
Thompson as they tackle the high profile
case against co-burger he faces murder
charges in the brutal stabbings of Fort
Idaho college students taking place at
an off-campus home in November the case
is still in its early stages as coburger
sits in the latex County Jail awaiting
his preliminary hearing which is set for
late June that hearing will determine
whether or not coburger's case will
actually go to trial and whether he'll
have to submit a plea let's break it
down Terry the judge issued a gag order
in this case which the Idaho Supreme
Court upheld this week what's the
purpose of the gag order and you think
that was the right decision I do think
it was the right decision and the whole
purpose of a gag order is to protect
particularly the defendant but all the
parties they want to make sure that they
don't tank that jury pool one way or the
other so not talking about the case is
what is going to protect that jury pool
and judge Marshall did Issue a very
widespread sweeping order that no one
could talk to the Press not the lawyers
not law enforcement or anyone else
associated with the case so it was a
widespread order but the Supreme Court
said five to zero that it should be in
place and it was actually the media who
petitioned to say look we have a First
Amendment right it's freedom of the
press we should be able to talk about it
but and can you know the Supreme Court
said no you can't this is just going to
be too prejudicial for the parties
involved particularly defendant so I
think it was the right decision but I'm
hoping that ultimately when the trial
comes it'll be an open trial and we can
all be in there listening to it and
writing whatever we need to about the
case well there's so many questions that
we have and we're kind of filling in the
pieces guessing but that's just the way
it happens when you have a gag order in
place I completely understand but from
you know someone from the media we're
trying to tell the full story a little
bit difficult all right Brian former
homicide public defender why would the
prosecution look to add prosecutors to
this case I mean what's the advantage
there and can we expect the same from
Brian coburger's defense so Jesse a
homicide case with one victim is
difficult but four and the forensic and
the digital evidence all just make it
that much more difficult lawyers don't
go to school as you know to learn about
forensics or or pinging of cell phones
and so where are there are so many
unique and specialized areas of of
information that an attorney needs to
master prosecutors will often have
attorneys know all of the case but then
really dive deep into one issue over the
other in terms of your second part of
the question should we expect the
defense to do the same that
unfortunately as a former defense
attorney comes the issue of funding is
there enough funding to have other
attorneys defense attorneys sorry jump
on the case to help with the
specialization of pinging cell phones
forensic for this victim uh forensic for
that victim the DNA on this victim and
that's when you see a robust and very
strong case on both sides and that's
what I think everyone should be hoping
for in order to find Justice all right
all gears ahead towards that preliminary
hearing we'll see what happens Brian
Terry thank you so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on the
daily we're going to see you next time
as we discuss Justice in America
foreign